I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作独家的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。你好。嗨。
We're really tired today. We are. We still have young kids. I had one that just could not fall asleep last night. I just had insomnia last night. Oh, that's rough. So we're two very unrested people. And yet I'm very excited about today's episode, The Delivery Part One.
我们今天真的很累。确实。我们还有年幼的孩子。我有一个昨晚怎么也睡不着。我昨晚刚失眠。哦，那太难受了。所以我们是两个极度缺乏睡眠的人。然而我对今天的剧集《分娩（上）》感到非常兴奋。
This is huge. That's what she said. Before we get into this, can I just say congratulations to Sam, Cassie, Jenna, and myself because we won a Webby. We did. Yes. Yes. Thank you guys and thank you so much for voting for us.
这太棒了。她就是这么说的。在我们进入正题之前，我能先向山姆、卡西、珍娜和我自己表示祝贺吗，因为我们赢得了威比奖。我们确实赢了。是的。谢谢大家，非常感谢大家为我们投票。
We love you guys. We love doing this and we just wanted to start off with a thank you. Well, I think that's a great way to start. Angela has also started her day, even though you're tired, wearing your Bassmaster merch. You're all dressed to exercise and I'm so impressed because, I mean, I don't exercise on days when I don't sleep well. I thought if I wore like sporty stuff, there might be a chance I'd be sporty. And I love rocking my Bassmasters hoodie, guys.
我们爱你们。我们热爱做这件事，我们只想以感谢开头。嗯，我认为这是个很好的开端。安吉拉今天也开始了新的一天，尽管你很累，却穿着你的巴斯大师（Bassmaster）周边。你打扮得准备去运动，我太佩服了，因为我的意思是，我睡眠不好的日子从不去运动。我觉得如果我穿得像运动风，我可能就有机会变得运动。而且我喜欢穿我的巴斯大师连帽衫，伙计们。
It's really cute. Bassmaster is doing some good merch. Shout out to the Bassmaster merch. Come out. All right. Today is season six, episode 17, written by Daniel Chun and directed by Seth Gordon. I'm going to give you a summary. Do it.
这真的很可爱。巴斯大师出了一些不错的周边。向巴斯大师周边致敬。出来吧。好的。今天是第六季第17集，由丹尼尔·陈编剧，塞思·戈登执导。我来给你们做一个总结。来吧。
Pam has gone into labor at work. I'm sorry. I need a lamp. I'm sorry to interrupt you. I don't have a lamp and I can't really see, so I'm going to drag one over one second. Okay. No problem. Tired eyes need a lamp.
潘在公司羊水破了要生了。对不起。我需要一盏灯。抱歉打扰你。我没有灯，而且我实在看不见，所以我等一下要搬一盏过来。好的。没问题。疲惫的眼睛需要一盏灯。
You know what? I stumbled on the summary, so I'm going to give it another shot. Maybe give it another shot. Now I can see. Well, now I'm jealous of all your light. You want me to drag a lamp over for you? I'm going to drag. Jenny, you can have a lamp.
你知道吗？我刚才总结得磕磕绊绊的，所以我要再试一次。也许再试一次。现在我能看见了。好吧，现在我嫉妒你们所有的光了。你想让我为你搬一盏灯过来吗？我要搬。珍娜，你可以有一盏灯。
I'm going to drag. You know what? Everybody gets a lamp. Cassie, you want a lamp? I can only hear that in the Oprah voices. She's like, you get a lamp. You get a lamp and you get a lamp. All right.
我要搬。你知道吗？每个人都有一盏灯。卡西，你想要一盏灯吗？我只能用奥普拉的语气听到这个声音。她就像是，你有一盏灯。你有一盏灯，你有一盏灯。好吧。
I just want to say, you made fun of me when we were writing our book. You made fun of me when I was cleaning out my garage and I had all those old lamps saved. Who wants a lamp now? Who wants a working lamp with a little rewiring? All those lamps are good lamps. Here's my question. You asked me when I'm going to use all the baskets I hoard, but when are you going to rewire a lamp, lady?
我只想说，我们写书的时候你取笑过我。当我清理车库并保留了所有那些旧灯时，你取笑过我。现在谁想要一盏灯？谁想要一盏只要稍微重新接线就能用的好灯？所有那些灯都是好灯。我的问题是：你问过我什么时候会用到我囤积的所有篮子，但是你什么时候会给一盏灯重新接线呢，女士？
When's that happening? I think you should know that in my retirement, I'm going to become a lamp rewiring expert. Oh, I can't wait for our garage sales when we're old ladies with our rewired lamps and our baskets. All right. Let's take another stab at this summary, shall we? Let's do it. All right.
那什么时候发生？我想你们应该知道，在我退休后，我将成为一名灯具重新接线专家。哦，我等不及我们在老去后带着重新接线的灯和篮子去办车库大甩卖了。好吧。让我们再试一次这个总结，好吗？来吧。好吧。
Pam has gone into labor at work and she doesn't want to check into the hospital until after midnight because their health insurance only covers a two-night stay. Meanwhile, Dwight hatches a plan to have his own baby so he can be a more competitive sales person. That's what's happening. It's a lot happening. Fast fact number one, this episode originally aired on March 4th, 2010, and you know, this episode is two parts.
潘在公司里开始临盆，她不想在午夜之前去医院，因为他们的医疗保险只承担两晚的住宿。与此同时，德怀特策划了一个生自己孩子的计划，这样他就能成为一个更具竞争力的销售员。这就是发生的事情。事情好多。第一快讯，这集最初于2010年3月4日播出，你知道，这一集分为两部分。
There's a part one and a part two, they were both aired together as a one-hour special. It was later separated into two episodes, which was done for syndication because syndication only takes half-hour episodes. Each of these parts were actually written and directed by completely different teams. So part one was written by Danny Chun and directed by Seth Gordon. That's what we're talking about today. And part two was written by Charlie Grandy and directed by Harold Ramis. And while they were separate episodes, they did all kind of consult on the whole thing.
有一个第一部分和一个第二部分，它们作为一个小时的特别节目一起播出。后来为了联合播出被分成了两集，因为联合播出只接受半小时的剧集。每一部分实际上都是由完全不同的团队编剧和执导的。所以第一部分由丹尼·陈编剧，塞思·戈登执导。这就是我们今天讨论的内容。第二部分由查理·格兰迪编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯执导。虽然它们是独立的剧集，但他们确实对整件事都进行了一定程度的咨询。
Yeah, you know, there is a DVD commentary for this episode and on it are you, Greg Daniels, the writers of part one and two, Danny Chun and Charlie Grandy, and the director of the first delivery, Seth Gordon. And Jenna, right out of the gate on the DVD commentary, the very first thing said was Greg asking you what it was like to wear the fake pregnancy belly. And if you were happy to be rid of it, what did I say? You had a lot to say, a lot that you've shared here about how uncomfortable it was and how long it took you to go pee and change clothes.
是的，你知道，这一集有一个DVD评论音轨，上面有你、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、第一和第二部分的编剧丹尼·陈和查理·格兰迪，以及第一次分娩的导演塞思·戈登。珍娜，在DVD评论的一开始，说的第一件事就是格雷格问你戴着假孕肚是什么感觉。如果你很高兴摆脱它，我说什么了？你有很多话要说，你在节目中分享了很多关于它有多不舒服，以及你上厕所和换衣服花了多长时间。
But it just cracked me up that the first thing talked about on the delivery was your fake belly. Well, in this episode, I have on the largest of all the bellies because this is her birthing day and it was the most uncomfortable. But I have to say, I don't know if I mentioned this on the commentary. I continued to wear a belly for several episodes after this because in real life, a woman's belly doesn't just like shrink back to normal after they have a baby. So after Pam has her baby, I continued to wear like belly B for a while.
但这让我觉得很有趣，关于分娩讨论的第一件事竟然是你的假肚子。好吧，在这集里，我戴着所有肚子里面最大的一的一个，因为这是她的生产日，也是最不舒服的。但我不得不说，我不知道我是否在评论中提到过这事。在此之后的几集里，我继续戴着一个肚子，因为在现实生活中，女人的肚子在生完孩子后不会马上缩回正常状态。所以在潘生完孩子后，我继续戴了一段时间的B号肚子。
You know, Angela Martin did not. I know. We'll get there. We'll get there. And also some great deleted scenes that didn't make it in and some scenes that are in the shooting draft. I'm going to sprinkle those throughout the episode. Oh, great.
你知道，安吉拉·马丁可没有。我知道。我们会讲到的。此外，还有一些没有被剪进去的精彩删减片段，以及拍摄剧本中的一些场景。我将把这些点缀在整集节目中。哦，太棒了。
Fast fact number two is a fan question from Dana in Clarksville, Tennessee. Why on earth does Pam choose to have all her major life events in the office? She came to work before her wedding. She came to work before art school. And now she is choosing to fully labor at work instead of in the comfort of her own home. Is the Dunder Mifflin paid time off policy that bad? This is a hilarious question. I love it.
第二快讯来自田纳西州克拉克斯维尔的达娜的一个粉丝提问。为什么潘偏偏要把她所有的人生大事都放在办公室里举办？她结婚前来了公司。她去艺术学校前来了公司。现在她选择在办公室里彻底分娩，而不是在自己舒适的家中。邓德米夫林的带薪休假政策真的有那么糟糕吗？这是一个非常搞笑的问题。我很喜欢。
Yeah. I love that she's like, Pam, what is up? Dana, I hear you. We talked about why did Holly come to work before she moved to Nashua? I know. She came to work for 30 minutes in her work clothes and then got into a giant truck and drove to Nashua. Why?
是的。我喜欢她那种，潘，怎么回事？达娜，我听到你的心声了。我们讨论过为什么霍莉在搬去纳什和之前还要来上班？我知道。她穿着工作服来上班30分钟，然后上了一辆大卡车开往纳什和。为什么？
Well, writer Danny Chun addresses this question in an interview that he did for OfficeTelly.com shortly after this episode aired. OfficeTelly.com has great interviews with cast and crew members, like immediately with cast and crew members that are just terrific. You all should check them out. Danny said that the biggest challenges in making this episode were, number one, making a baby episode that didn't feel like a retread of every other sitcom baby episode. And number two, making a baby episode for a workplace comedy because that's what we
嗯，编剧丹尼·陈在该剧播出后不久为OfficeTelly.com做的一次采访中回答了这个问题。OfficeTelly.com有对演员和剧组成员的精彩采访，就像立即对演员和剧组成员进行的采访一样，非常棒。你们都应该去看看。丹尼说，制作这一集最大的挑战是，第一，制作一集不像是老调重弹其他情景喜剧生子情节的生子剧。第二，为职场喜剧制作一集生子剧，因为我们就是
are. Oh, that's so true. Yeah. Yeah. He said, ultimately, problem number two helped with problem number one because one thing you haven't seen a lot of is people laboring in their workplace. That's true. So.
这样的人。哦，太对了。是的。是的。他说，最终，问题二有助于解决问题一，因为你没怎么见过的一件事就是人们在职场里临盆。确实如此。所以。
Yeah. You know, I'm sitting here trying to think of shows that we watch growing up and did anyone go into labor and spend their day of labor at work? And I can't think of one. So this does feel really unique. I think they figured it out. Yeah. Well, fastback number three is a question from Evelyn in Michigan who wanted to know,
是的。你知道，我坐在这里试图回想我们从小看过的节目，有没有人临盆并在工作日里度过临盆的一天？我想不出一个。所以这感觉真的很独特。我想他们弄懂了。好吧，第三快讯是来自密歇根州的伊芙琳的一个问题，她想知道，
Jenna, had you ever been pregnant before this episode filmed? And if not, how did you prepare for the part? She also wants to know, do I ever look back at the scenes now that I do have kids and think about maybe parts of my performance that I would have added or taken away now that I know what real labor is like? And do I think that acting would have been easier if I had been through it? All right. I'm going to unpack this Evelyn.
珍娜，在拍摄这一集之前你怀孕过吗？如果没有，你是如何为这个角色做准备的？她还想问，既然我现在有了孩子，我回看这些场景时，会不会想到一些因为我现在知道了真正的分娩是什么样的而想要添加或删减的表演部分？你认为如果我经历过这些，演戏会不会更容易？好吧。我要来拆解一下伊芙琳的这个问题。
So first of all, no, I did not have kids in real life. I had not been pregnant before when I filmed this episode. So after I got the script and I realized I would be doing a lot of laboring, I wanted to know what does that look like? So I watched a ton of YouTube videos. This is just, I have to say, an actor's dream. So actual videos of people going into labor, like maybe their spouse filmed them or something on YouTube?
所以首先，不，我在现实生活中没有孩子。拍摄这一集之前我没有怀孕过。所以在我拿到剧本并意识到我要有很多分娩戏份后，我想知道那是什么样子的？所以我看了大量的YouTube视频。我必须说，这简直是演员的梦寐以求。所以是人们临盆的实际视频，比如可能是他们的伴侣在YouTube上拍摄的视频之类的？
Yeah. And they have like baby stories of documentaries of the labor process from contraction to having a baby. Wow. So I just watched a lot of stuff about what happens to you when you're in labor and what it really looks like. You know? That's really cool.
是的，他们有诸如分娩过程记录片之类的育儿故事，从宫缩到生孩子。哇。所以我只是看了很多关于当你处于分娩状态时会发生什么以及它真正看起来是什么样的东西。你知道吗？这真的很酷。
But I have to say, I was really confused by Pam's choice to not go to the hospital. I understood the logic behind why she wasn't going, but I did go to the writers and say, I just am not understanding why a woman would put off going to the hospital for so long, especially with her first pregnancy. Yes. And one of the writers told me that their friend actually did this, that she put off going to the hospital. It was not because of like an HMO issue, but because she was afraid to give birth.
但我必须说，我对潘不肯去医院的选择真的很困惑。我理解她不去背后的逻辑，但我确实去找了编剧并说，我只是不明白为什么一个女人会把去医院的时间推迟那么久，尤其是她的第一胎。是的。其中一个位编剧告诉我，他们的一个朋友实际上就是这么做的，她推迟了去医院的时间。这并不是因为HMO（健康维护组织）的问题，而是因为她害怕生孩子。
So she was like in denial. Her family was like, you are going to give birth. Like it is happening. And she was like, no, I think I'm good, I think I'm fine. And they had to like really like talk her into the reality of her situation. Ultimately, we find out that's why Pam's not going, you know, we'll get there. But that gave me something to hold on to that this wasn't just in Pam's mind. This wasn't just about an HMO thing.
所以她就像是在否认现实。她的家人就像是，你要生了。这就要发生了。而她就像是，不，我觉得我很好，我觉得我没事。他们不得不像那样真正地跟她谈论她处境的现实。最终，我们发现这就是潘不去的原因，你知道的，我们等下会讲到。但那给了我一些可以坚持的东西，这不仅仅是潘脑海中的想法。这不仅仅是关于HMO的问题。
This was a little bit of like denial. Right. And she was sort of cloaking it with the HMO. Yes. Well, Greg shared on the commentary that he was a big champion of this HMO storyline. He said that he and Danny double checked if it's true that if you wait until after midnight and you check into a hospital that you get more time covered by your insurance, that is true.
这有点像是逃避现实。没错。而且她还用HMO作掩护。是的。好吧，格雷格在评论中分享说，他是这个HMO故事情节的坚定支持者。他说他和丹尼仔细核实过，如果你等到午夜之后再去医院登记住院，你的保险就能涵盖更多的时间，这是真的。
Greg also said it was a consideration he and his wife were making with their first child. Oh, it's a real thing. I mean, I don't know if folks are listening here that live outside of the United States, but you always are thinking, okay, what does my insurance cover? Right. Yeah. I actually got a lot of mail from people outside of the United States who were slightly confused by this storyline.
格雷格还说，这是他和妻子在生第一个孩子时考虑过的事情。哦，这是真事。我的意思是，我不知道有没有住在美国以外的人在收听，但你总是会想，好吧，我的保险涵盖什么？对的。是的。我实际上收到了很多来自美国以外的人的信件，他们对这个故事情节略感困惑。
You know, a lot of our listeners in the UK, they don't have this consideration. People wrote in and said, in my country, you go to the hospital or the doctor when you need it and it's free and we're a little confused by the storyline. And I have to say, I did live in London for like almost a year and I worked there and I experienced their health care system. Wow. Yeah. It's a real big relief.
你知道，我们在英国的许多听众，他们没有这种顾虑。人们写信说，在我的国家，当你需要的时候，你去医院或找医生，这是免费的，我们对这个故事情节有点困惑。我必须说，我确实在伦敦住了将近一年，我在那里工作，我体验了他们的医疗保健系统。哇。是的。这真是一个巨大的解脱。
I remember we went to the emergency room with our daughter, oh no, immediately my first thought is emergency rooms are so expensive. But, you know, I was there on a work visa, so I was paying taxes and I had registered to be part of the health care system, but we had only just arrived and I hadn't gotten a doctor yet. So we went to the emergency room and they fixed her up and they gave us a prescription as we were leaving. I said, what do I owe you and they said nothing and I said, oh, are you going to bill me?
我记得我们带着女儿去了急诊室，哦不，我的第一反应是急诊室太贵了。但是，你知道的，我是拿着工作签证在那里的，所以我交了税，而且我注册加入了医疗保健系统，但我们才刚到，我还没有找到医生。所以我们去了急诊室，他们给她治好了，并在我们离开时给我们开了一个处方。我说，我欠你多少钱，他们说不用，我说，哦，你们要给我寄账单吗？
And they said, what are you talking about? And I said, what are you talking about? And they said, no, you just leave now. I asked them like five times, I was like, I am confused. I just leave with the medicine. How much is the medicine? The medicine is free. And I was like, do you need me to fill something out?
他们说，你在说什么？我说，你在说什么？他们说，不，你现在就可以走了。我问了他们大概五次，我说，我很困惑。我拿着药直接走人吗？药多少钱？药是免费的。然后我说，你需要我填什么表格吗？
They're like, no, just go and be well was what they said. And that happened every time I went to the doctor there. It was zero dollars and zero stress and anytime anything went wrong, the only thing we had to worry about was getting well. So yes, I see why the male from other places, you know, that their tension in this episode is like an unrelatable concept. Yeah. Wow.
他们说，不，走吧，祝你早日康复，他们就是这么说的。我每次去那里的医生那里都是这样的。那是零美元，零压力，每当有任何不对劲的时候，我们唯一需要担心的事情就是赶快好起来。所以是的，我明白来自其他地方的信件，你知道的，他们在这一集中的纠结是一个无法产生共鸣的概念。是的。哇。
Well, that's amazing. I know, right? But he also shared that his dad in real life is a pediatrician and he said it was really cool because he got to ask his dad a lot of questions and get his advice in writing this episode. Oh, well, I remember that. I remember that his dad was a pediatrician. That's so fun, I think for him, you know, like, because how many times do those worlds
嗯，那太棒了。我知道，对吧？但他也分享说，他的爸爸在现实生活中是一名儿科医生，他说这真的很酷，因为他在写这一集时可以问他爸爸很多问题并听取他的建议。哦，好吧，我记得这个。我记得他爸爸是一名儿科医生。这太有趣了，我想对他来说，你知道的，因为那些世界有多少次
cross? Yes. And then Jen on the commentary, like everyone that had had kids sort of shared a little like Charlie shared that he has three kids and Seth shared that he and his wife were expecting a baby and their due date was the week after we filmed this episode. Oh my gosh. Yeah. So he had his phone on the whole time, I mean, just in case.
交汇？是的。然后在珍娜的评论中，就像所有生过孩子的人都分享了一点，比如查理分享说他有三个孩子，塞思分享说他和他的妻子正期待着一个孩子，他们的预产期就在我们拍摄这一集之后的那个星期。哦，天哪。是的。所以他整把手机都开着，我的意思是，以防万一。
So he was filming a woman faking labor and his wife might go into labor at any time. Yes. Oh my goodness. Well, I remember all that, Angela. I remember all of the people on set who had kids began sharing all their stories. All of their birthing stories. We did. It was amazing.
所以他正在拍摄一个假装临盆的女人，而他的妻子随时可能临盆。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，我记得所有这些，安吉拉。我记得片场所有有孩子的那些人都开始分享他们的所有故事。他们所有的分娩故事。我们确实如此。太棒了。
John and I were eating it up. We were just going around and being like, tell us everything because neither one of us had kids yet. Well, lady, that's all I got for fast facts. Before we take a break and get into this episode, I just have to point out something, which is how amazing you and John are in this episode. You guys are amazing. I hadn't seen this episode for years and I was watching it as a fan of Jim and Pam, but
约翰和我当时听得津津有味。我们只是四处走动并说，把一切都告诉我们，因为我们两个都还没有孩子。好吧，女士，关于快讯我就知道这么多了。在我们休息并进入这一集之前，我必须指出一件事，那就是你和约翰在这一集里有多么惊艳。你们太棒了。我已经好几年没看过这一集了，我是作为一个珍姆夫妇的粉丝在看的，但
at the same time, thinking, holy crap, my best friend is crushing it. Lady, thank you so much. Just really phenomenal performances by the two of you. Just amazing. Well, let me say this. When I was watching this episode, I got very excited because D'Angela is back. Oh my gosh. I almost like leapt out of my seat.
与此同时，心里在想，天哪，我的好朋友太棒了。女士，非常非常感谢。你们两个人的表演简直太卓越了。简直太棒了。好吧，让我这么说吧。当我看到这一集的时候，我非常兴奋，因为德安吉拉回来了。哦，天哪。我差一点从座位上跳起来。
I was so excited. I can't wait to talk about it. All right, well, we'll take a break and when we come back, we have some awkward love and some sweet love to discuss. This episode opens up with Pam making some sales calls. She wants to tie up loose ends before she takes her maternity leave. As a result, she's explaining this to her clients and they're putting in orders. Yeah.
我太兴奋了。我迫不及待地想聊聊这个了。好吧，那我们休息一下，当我们回来时，有一些尴尬的爱和一些甜蜜的爱需要讨论。这一集以潘打一些销售电话开场。她想在休产假前处理好手头未了的事情。因此，她正在向客户解释这一点，而他们也正在下订单。是的。
They're so happy for her of it. She's having a baby. Dwight is furious. You think she's using her baby to get sales? Yeah. Dwight decides, well, he's going to use his personal life to increase his sales, but it doesn't go well. No.
他们为她感到高兴。她要生孩子了。德怀特气急败坏。你觉得她在利用自己的孩子来拉销售额？是的。德怀特决定，好吧，他要利用自己的个人生活来提高他的销售额，但这并不顺利。不。
Because he's talking about like, Moe's has like a, gets an infection. Yeah. No one is ordering extra paper. No. So he has a talking head where he says he needs a baby or else he'll never outperform Pam and Jim. And he also says he has a gaping hole in his life and he sometimes wakes up cradling like a large gourd.
因为他在谈论诸如莫斯（Moe's）感染了某种东西。是的。没有人额外订购纸张。不。所以他有一个访谈镜头，在其中他说他需要一个孩子，否则他永远无法超越潘和吉姆。他还说他生活中有一个巨大的空洞，他有时醒来时会抱着一个大葫芦。
I think Dwight wants a baby. Why are their gourds just hanging around his bedroom? Good question. Well, guess what? This was not the cold open in the shooting draft. The shooting draft had an elaborate Jim prank on Dwight. Really? Yeah.
我觉得德怀特想要个孩子。为什么他们的卧室里到处挂着葫芦？好问题。好吧，你猜怎么着？这不是拍摄剧本中的冷开场。拍摄剧本有一个精细的吉姆整蛊德怀特的桥段。真的吗？是的。
It's sort of like a Wiley E. Coyote. Okay. Kind of prank. Listen to what it said in the shooting draft, Dwight enters for the day and stops cold. A box of donuts sits on the reception desk. Below it is a crude wooden trap door on the floor. And a large lever sits next to Jim's desk. Dwight says, oh Jim, this is sad.
这有点像威利·柯Y（Wiley E. Coyote）。好的。那种恶作剧。听听拍摄剧本里是怎么写的，德怀特像往常一样走进来，突然停住了。接待桌上放着一盒甜甜圈。下面是一个粗糙的木制活板门。吉姆的桌子旁边放着一个大杠杆。德怀特说，哦，吉姆，这太可悲了。
I thought you had moved on as a human. He says, you know, obviously I'm not dumb enough to fall for a fake trap door. Jim's like, it's not fake. Dwight goes over and jumps on the trap door and nothing happens. And he sort of scoffs at Jim like, ha, see, he walks over to his desk and there's a piece of floss tied to the lever going up to the ceiling above the trap door. And then Dwight's like, oh, what am I supposed to do? Pull on the string and then something's going to fall on my head.
我以为你作为一个人类已经成长了。他说，你知道，很明显我不会傻到掉进一个假的活板门里。吉姆说，这不是假的。德怀特走过去跳上活板门，什么也没发生。他有点嘲笑吉姆，哈，你看，他走到他的桌子旁，发现一根牙线绑在通往活板门上方天花板的杠杆上。然后德怀特说，哦，我是打算怎么做呢？拉一下绳子，然后有什么东西会砸到我头上。
And as he's saying this, Jim has a pie ready to throw in Dwight's face. But he's like so slow doing it, Dwight's like, what are you doing? None of this pays off for Jim. All of his hard work making the fake trap door, doing the string and the lever, all because he wanted to surprise him with the pie. But Dwight is like, Jim, you're holding a pie. And then Jim has a talking head that's like, well, I have to admit, I'm a little rusty. I should have practiced with Pam.
就在他这么说的时候，吉姆准备好了一个派要砸到德怀特脸上。但他动作太慢了，德怀特说，你在干什么？这一切对吉姆来说都没有回报。他制作假活板门、弄绳子和杠杆的所有辛苦工作，全都是因为他想用派给他一个惊喜。但德怀特却说，吉姆，你手里拿着个派。然后吉姆有一个访谈镜头，大意是，好吧，我必须承认，我有点生疏了。我应该和潘一起练习的。
But you know, I got a kid coming. Obviously, there's no excuses. Oh, this used to come so easy. Oh, I know. But this prank is so elaborate, like so much went into it. And it didn't work, which I thought was sort of interesting because Jim's pranks always work. Yeah. Well, I feel like I remember shooting this.
但你知道，我有个孩子快要出生了。显然，没有任何借口。哦，这以前来得太容易了。哦，我知道。但这个恶作剧太精心了，投入了如此多的心血。而且没有成功，我觉得这有点有趣，因为吉姆的恶作剧总是成功的。是的。好吧，我觉得我记得拍这个。
We did. It's in the deleted scenes on the- Oh, so people can see it. They can see it. You got to go see this trap door. Well, this episode is going to open with Kevin and Pam in the kitchen. I loved the storyline. I feel like this was on a card on the wall, like Kevin and Pam dying together.
我们拍了。它在花絮里——哦，所以人们可以看到它。他们可以看到。你得去看看这个活板门。好吧，这一集将以凯文和潘在厨房里开场。我很喜欢这个故事情节。我觉得这就像墙上的一张卡片，比如凯文和潘一起死去。
We find out that Kevin knows a lot about food. He's cooked his way through the Julia Childs cookbook. And now he's halfway through the Twilight cookbook, like Twilight the movie. Yeah. And it's a real thing. No, it is not. It is a real cookbook called Love at First Bite, the unofficial Twilight cookbook by Gina Meyers. Wait a second.
我们发现凯文对食物很了解。他照着朱莉娅·蔡尔德的食谱一路做下来。现在他已经进行到《暮光之城》食谱的一半了，就像电影《暮光之城》那种。是的，这是真事。不，这不是真的。这是一本名为《第一口之爱：非官方暮光之城食谱》的真实食谱，作者是吉娜·迈尔斯。等一下。
Vampires don't eat. How can they have a cookbook? Well, here's what it says. Beautiful Bella Swan will be serving up some scrumptious delights to satisfy even the pickiest Puritan vegetarian vampires. Inner twined in the pages of Love at First Bite, you will find Belle's lasagna, Harry's famous fish fry, blushing Bella Punch. And I dare you to eat pizza, Edward, just to name a few. I mean, all I can think about is vampires eating people. Well, I hear you.
吸血鬼不吃东西。他们怎么会有食谱？好吧，上面是这么写的。美丽的贝拉·斯旺将提供一些美味的诱惑，以满足哪怕是最挑剔的清教徒素食吸血鬼。在《第一口之爱》的书页间交织着，你会发现贝拉千层面、哈里炸鱼名菜、羞涩贝拉宾治酒。我敢你吃披萨，爱德华，这只是举几个例子。我的意思是，我脑子里想的全都是吸血鬼吃人。好吧，我懂你。
I think your beet vodka should be in the vampire cookbook because it looks like blood. You did keep saying that. I know. Well, the cookbook author, Gina Meyers, has done several unique themed cookbooks. Like, has she done another movie franchise? Like, is it like the Fast and the Furious cookbook? She did one for the television show Bewitched. Oh, cute.
我觉得你的甜菜伏特加应该加入吸血鬼食谱，因为它看起来像血。你一直在这么说。我知道。嗯，食谱作者吉娜·迈尔斯做过几本独特的特色食谱。比如，她做过另一个电影系列吗？比如，有没有像是《速度与激情》食谱这样的东西？她为电视剧《家有仙妻》做过一本。哦，真可爱。
Yeah. The magic of Bewitched trivia and the magic of Bewitched cookbook. She's also, by the way, the proud winner of the prestigious Gourmand International Cookbook Award in 2012 for her fundraising cookbook, Hope for Haiti. Love that. I will tell you, Brian and I delighted in doing these scenes. They were so fun. We love second breakfast, lunch, second lunch, and first dinner. We love ultra-feast.
是的。《家有仙妻》问答魔力与《家有仙妻》食谱魔力。顺便说一句，她还是2012年著名的美食家国际食谱奖的自豪得主，获奖作品是她的筹款食谱《希望之海地》。我很喜欢这个。我得告诉你，布莱恩和我非常乐意拍这些场景。它们太有趣了。我们喜欢第二早餐、午餐、第二午餐和第一晚餐。我们喜欢超级盛宴。
We love all of it. By the way, speaking of cookbooks, you know, Brian Baumgartner has a cookbook coming out in September called Seriously Good Chili Cookbook, as he should. Right? Right. If anyone's going to have a chili cookbook, it best be Brian. So look for that. I have a background catch. Oh.
我们喜欢这一切。顺便说一句，说到食谱，你知道，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳有一本将于9月出版的食谱，叫做《极其美味的辣椒食谱》，他理应如此。对吧？如果有人要出一本辣椒食谱，最好是布莱恩。所以留意一下那个。我有一个背景捕捉。哦。
At one minute, 38 seconds, did you notice that behind Kevin, someone opens the refrigerator door and then closes it, but you never see who was there? I didn't notice. I thought that was odd. I thought, why would they frame up Jenna and Brian in a two-shot when the scene's just about them and then let someone open the refrigerator door into Brian's back? Who did it? Well, I went to the shooting draft, but it's also in the deleted scenes. It was Meredith. Meredith interrupts them and says, hey, Pam, do you remember if you're having a boy or girl?
在一分38秒时，你有没有注意到在凯文身后，有人打开了冰箱门然后又关上了，但你从来没看到是谁在那儿？我没注意到。我觉得这很奇怪。我想，为什么当这个场景只是关于珍娜和布莱恩时，他们要以双人镜头来框住珍娜和布莱恩，然后让某人把冰箱门开到布莱恩的背上呢？是谁干的？好吧，我查了拍摄剧本，但它也在删减片段中。那是梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思打断了他们并说，嘿，潘，你还记得你是怀男孩还是女孩吗？
Pam says, with some sass, I kind of recall choosing not to find out. Meredith says, aren't you special? Which really made me laugh because when I was pregnant, I had that moment where I was like, maybe I won't find out the sex. I'll let it be a surprise. And I remember saying to my mom, mom, we're thinking about having it be a surprise. And she goes, well, why? Life is full of surprises. You don't need this one.
帕姆带点讽刺地说，我好像记得我选择过不提前知道。梅雷迪思说，看把你特殊得。这真的让我笑出来，因为我怀孕时也有过那种时刻，心想，也许我不去查性别吧，留着当个惊喜。我记得我对妈妈说，妈，我们正考虑让它成为一个惊喜。她就说，好吧，为什么？生活充满了惊喜，你不需要这一个。
She was so annoyed because she wanted to buy baby outfits. She was making a quilt. She needed to know. Yeah. But it did crack me up. Meredith goes on to say, well, if it is a boy, I met a guy at Paintball who is a circumcision artist. Oh, yeah. And Meredith says, if you say my name, I get 25 bucks and I'll give you five.
她当时好生气，因为她想买婴儿衣服。她当时在做百衲被，她需要知道。对，但那真的逗死我了。梅雷迪思接着说，好吧，如果是个男孩，我在彩弹射击场遇到过一个割包皮艺术家。哦，是的。梅雷迪思说，如果你说出我的名字，我能拿25块，我分你5块。
Oh. To which Pam says, thanks, but we already have a paintball circumcision guy. But that's why the fridge opens and shuts behind Kevin's back in the scene. Good detective work. I like it. Well, listen, you know, Michael is very excited about Pam's contraptions. Oh, her contraptions. Yeah.
哦。帕姆对此说，谢谢，但我们已经有专属的彩弹割包皮师傅了。不过这就是为什么凯文背后冰箱门在这个镜头里开开关关。不错的侦探工作，我喜欢。好了，听着，你知道的，迈克尔对帕姆的宫缩非常兴奋。哦，她的宫缩。对。
Really making his day. Well, I have another background catch. Oh, I know. Two back to back. Lady, I'm on a roll. Did you notice at two minutes, 47 seconds, that Stanley is not at his desk? No, I didn't. Pam is having contraptions.
真的让他这一天都过得很开心。好吧，我还有另一个背景彩蛋。哦，我知道，接连两个，天哪，我状态真好。你有没有注意到在两分四十七秒时，斯坦利不在他的座位上？不，我没注意到。帕姆正在宫缩。
Michael wants her to go to the hospital. Everyone's weighing in. Where's Stanley? Where is Stanley? I will tell you. I went to the shooting draft and also in deleted scenes. This was a much bigger scene. And there was a lot of Stanley and Meredith's sass.
迈克尔想让她去医院。每个人都在发表意见。斯坦利呢？斯坦利在哪里？我来告诉你。我去看了拍摄剧本，还有删减片段。这本来是一场更大的戏，里面有很多斯坦利和梅雷迪思的俏皮话。
Jim says, guys, it's not baby time. Stanley says, it is, however, baby Ruth time. And then he mutters under his breath, pregnant coworker, let's all drop everything. Jeez, Stanley. And he gets up and he goes to the break room to get his baby Ruth. And that's why Stanley isn't here the whole time. And this also starts a Meredith runner that got cut. She is wearing brand new high top sneakers.
吉姆说，伙计们，现在还不是生孩子的时候。斯坦利说，不过，现在是吃雷德斯巧克力的时间。然后他咕哝着说，怀孕的同事，让我们放下手头的一切吧。天哪，斯坦利。然后他站起来去茶水间拿他的雷德斯巧克力。这就是为什么斯坦利整个过程都不在这里。这也开启了一条被删掉的梅雷迪思副线。她穿着崭新的高帮运动鞋。
Oh, this was her storyline in this episode was her new high tops. And she says, all I know is I haven't gotten one comment about my new high tops. Meredith, I mean, you wore them on the day that Pam is having contraptions at the office. I know. Meredith and Stanley are like, I'm out. I'm out. They're very annoyed. Everyone seems a little annoyed by all of the attention that is going Pam's way.
哦，她在这一集里的故事线就是她的新高帮鞋。她说，我只知道大家对我的新高帮鞋一句评论都没有。梅雷迪思，我的意思是，你在帕姆办公室宫缩的日子里穿它们。我知道。梅雷迪思和斯坦利就像是在说，我不管了，我受够了。他们非常恼火。每个人似乎都对所有注意力都集中在帕姆身上感到有点烦。
Except Kelly, who seems just worried. Well, Kelly is looking up pictures on her computer about, I guess, labor and delivery. That was a fakie website that she's looking at. Our graphics designer, Henry Sane, made that website. She says, during labor, they take your insights out and sometimes epidurals don't work. And sometimes you poop yourself. Oh my gosh. She's learning a lot.
除了凯莉，她看起来只是很担心。好吧，凯莉正在电脑上查关于我猜是分娩的照片。那是她看的一个假网站。我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩制作了那个网站。她说，分娩时，他们会把你的内脏拿出来，有时硬膜外麻醉会失效，有时你会拉裤子。噢天哪。她学到了很多。
So Kelly is like halfway right here. According to BabySunner, in most C sections, the bladder and intestines are moved aside so that your OBGYN can get them out of the way. And then they kind of lift the uterus out a little bit. But the organs are never like completely removed from your body, as Kelly kind of suggests. But she is right that a lot of times during vaginal labor, especially, you poop yourself. You poop.
所以凯莉这里差不多说对了一半。根据“宝贝森纳”网站的说法，在大多数剖腹产中，膀胱和肠道会被移到旁边，以便妇产科医生把它们挪开。然后他们会把子宫稍微提出来一点。但器官绝不会像凯莉暗示的那样被完全从体内取出。不过她说的对，很多时候在阴道分娩时，尤其是，你会拉裤子。你会拉。
You poop all your pushing. Well. And that happens and that's life and that's bringing life into the world and it's okay. It is okay. Just another reason I couldn't be an OBGYN is because I'd be afraid I'd move an organ the wrong way. But you wouldn't because you've gone to school. Oh, that's true.
你用力时会拉出来。好吧。这会发生，这就是生活，这就是把生命带到世界上，这没关系的。没关系的。这也是我当不成妇产科医生的另一个原因，因为我怕自己会把器官移错方向。但你不会，因为你上过学。哦，这倒也是。
You studied. Right. You, right now, with your current knowledge of intestines, could not be an OBGYN. But if I had gone to school. You could do it. Yes. Okay. Of course.
你学过。没错。你，现在，凭你对肠道的现有知识，是当不了妇产科医生的。但如果我上过学的话。你能做到。是的。好吧，当然。
Well, there were more talking heads during this big group scene that got deleted. They're on the DVD. First one starts a great Creed runner, Jenna. Some of it is in deleted scenes. Some of it is in the shooting draft. I've got to share it. Creed is going to tell you how Pam's birth is affecting him. Let's hear it.
好吧，在这个大型群戏中有更多被删掉的访谈镜头。它们在DVD上。第一个开启了一条伟大的克里德副线，珍娜。其中一些在删减片段里，一些在拍摄剧本里。我得分享一下。克里德要告诉你帕姆的生育是如何影响他的。我们听听。
Pam may be about to give birth. And if I understand anything about the cycle life and I do, that means somebody dies. And I think we all know whose number is up. Time to get my affairs in order. So wish me luck, my friends, as I go gently into that good night. Oh, my gosh, Creed thinks it's like a literal one to one. He does. And he's going to spend the rest of the episode getting his affairs in order.
帕姆可能快要生孩子了。如果我对生命循环还有点理解的话——我确实懂，这意味着有人要死了。我想我们都知道谁的大限已到。是时候把我的后事安排好了。所以祝我好运吧，我的朋友们，当我温柔地走进那个良夜。噢天哪，克里德以为这是一个字面上一对一的对应。他是这么想的。他打算花这一集的剩余时间来把后事安排好。
I'm going to share a few of those moments. And Michael shares what his role is in Pam's birth. I'm scared. My role in the birth of this child is that of the boss. Within that, there is none of the pain as associated with the mother's role. There is none of the responsibility, which is associated with the father's role. But in many cultures, the boss really plays no role at all in childbirth. So his role is the boss, but as he starts to talk it out, that role really plays no
我要分享其中几个时刻。迈克尔分享了他在帕姆生孩子这事里的角色。我很害怕。我在这个孩子出生过程中的角色是老板。在这个角色中，没有与母亲角色相关的痛苦，没有与父亲角色相关的责任。但在许多文化中，老板在分娩中其实根本不起任何作用。所以他的角色是老板，但当他开始把话说出口时，这个角色其实根本起不到任何
role. It just sort of made me laugh. You know, I suppose his role could be to let Pam go home and have a paid day off. That could be his role. That could be. He'd have to check with Joe Bennett. But then I guess also then he couldn't be there for it, which is ultimately more important to him.
作用。这只是让我觉得好笑。你知道，我猜他的角色可以是让帕姆回家并带薪休假一天。那可以是他的角色。也可以是。他得去问问乔·贝内特。但随后我猜那样他就不能在现场了，而这对他来说最终更重要。
Yeah. Yeah. Well, now we have the moment I did not know I needed so much. Dwight and Angela in the break room, once again, not speaking face to face, not looking at one another. Dwight has a proposal. He does. He starts out right out of the gate with Bear My Child.
对。对。好吧，现在迎来了我不知道自己如此需要的时刻。德怀特和安吉拉在茶水间里，再次没有面对面说话，没有看着对方。德怀特有一个求婚提议。确实。他一开门见山就说，生我的孩子。
Yeah. And Angela's like, excuse me? She says, excuse me, but she's immediately like delighted. Oh, excuse me. Oh, excuse me. In the shooting draft, there were two lines that preceded Dwight saying, Bear My Child, that got cut, but I wanted to read them to you. Dwight is looking at the vending machine.
对。而安吉拉的反应是，不好意思？她说，不好意思，但她马上又表现得很开心。哦，不好意思？哦，不好意思？在拍摄剧本里，在德怀特说出“生我的孩子”之前有两句台词被删了，但我想读给你们听。德怀特正看着自动售货机。
He says, hmm, there's a new flavor of hers chips, barbecue. Angela says, ugh, I must have missed the memo where Scranton is now Kansas City. And then there's a long pause and Dwight says, Bear My Child. Amazing. At four minutes, six seconds, I don't know if you notice, but I am holding my yogurt in my mouth. What? Yeah.
他说，嗯，有一种新口味的赫尔斯薯片，烧烤味的。安吉拉说，呃，我一定错过了斯克兰顿现在变成堪萨斯城的备忘录。然后是一段长久的沉默，德怀特说，生我的孩子。太惊艳了。在四分钟六秒时，我不知道你们有没有注意到，我正把酸奶含在嘴里。什么？对。
So I'm eating yogurt in this scene. Yeah. And when Dwight says, if you agree, say nothing. If you disagree, say anything, I just sort of made the choice to hold what I was eating in my mouth. Oh. I know it's really dorky. These are things you remember, though.
所以我在这个镜头里吃酸奶。对。当德怀特说，如果你同意，就什么也别说；如果你不同意，就随便说什么，我只是做出了把正在吃的东西含在嘴里的选择。哦。我知道这真的很书呆子气。不过这些都是你记住的事情。
And when I watched it, I was like, I like that I did that. It's funny you mentioned that because the detail that I noticed was that for the beginning of the scene, I couldn't see that you had a yogurt cup. I just saw that you had a bowl of grapes and a spoon in your hand. And I wrote down, is she eating grapes with a spoon? And then at the end of the scene, I see you scoop the yogurt and I was like, oh, it's yogurt. Yeah.
当我看到它时，我想，我喜欢我当时那么做。你提到这个很有趣，因为我注意到的细节是，在这个镜头的开头，我看不出来你有一个酸奶杯。我只看到你手里拿着一碗葡萄和一个勺子。我记下来的是，她是在用勺子吃葡萄吗？然后在镜头结尾，我看到你舀了酸奶，当时我就想，哦，原来是酸奶。对。
Angela is eating a lot in this episode. She eats later down in the warehouse. I don't know, I guess we just thought Angela should be eating all day today. Maybe you were just hungry this week. Maybe in real life. I was like, can I have a snack? Can I eat during this scene? Yeah.
安吉拉这一集里一直在吃东西。她后来在仓库里还在吃。我不知道，我猜我们当时只是觉得安吉拉今天应该一整天都在吃东西。也许你这周就是很饿。也许在现实生活中。我当时就问，我能吃个零食吗？我能在这个镜头里吃东西吗？对。
Well, you know, Pam's contractions, they're getting closer together. And Jim would really like to go to the hospital now. But Pam says, I'm good. We're going to go when they're five minutes apart. That's what the doctor said. And Jim said it was five to seven minutes, five to seven. We said seven. Pam's freaking out.
好吧，你知道的，帕姆的宫缩越来越频繁了。吉姆真的很想现在就去医院。但帕姆说，我很好。我们等间隔五分钟再去。医生是这么说的。吉姆说那是五到七分钟，五到七分钟。我们说的是七分钟。帕姆快急疯了。
He's starting to freak out. It's going to get worse for him as Pam also freaks out in her own way. This is sort of a fun thing they talked about on the commentary about how Jim and Pam are normally the rational thinking people in the office while everyone else is spiraling out. But in this episode, it's the reverse. Literally everyone is like, you guys go to the hospital. And Pam's like, noop. And it's really funny to see that flip.
他也开始抓狂了。随着帕姆也以她自己的方式抓狂，情况对他的打击会更大。他们在评论音轨里讨论过一件很有趣的事，平时吉姆和帕姆是办公室里保持理性和思考的人，而其他所有人都在失控。但在这一集里，情况完全反过来了。几乎所有人都说，你们去医院吧。而帕姆却说，不。看到这种反转真的很有趣。
I love John in this episode, and I love him in the next part too as well. He's so funny. I mean, this is John at his romantic comedy best. He's so funny, but then he also completely made me tear up. Yeah. I know. That's how he gets you. Yeah.
我很喜欢这一集里的约翰，我也同样很喜欢他在下一部分里的表现。他太搞笑了。我的意思是，这是处于浪漫喜剧巅峰状态的约翰。他太搞笑了，但随后他也完全把我弄哭了。对。我知道。他是怎么抓住你的。对。
That's the Krasinski special right there. Andy wants to offer this advice to the new parents to not get hung up on baby names. You know, he says he did not have the name Andy until the age of six, that before that he was Walter Jr. But then when his brother was born, they felt his brother better exemplified the name Walter Jr. So they renamed him Andrew. He was Walter until he was six years old?
那就是克拉辛斯基式的绝招。安迪想给新手父母提出这样的建议：不要纠结于婴儿名字。你知道，他说他直到六岁才有“安迪”这个名字，在此之前他叫小沃尔特。但后来当他弟弟出生时，他们觉得他弟弟更能体现“小沃尔特”这个名字。所以他们把他重新命名为安德鲁。他叫沃尔特一直叫到六岁？
Yeah. And then they renamed him Andrew. That's bonkers. And his younger brother is Walter Jr. now. They did share on the commentary that they delight in just giving Andy so much backstory. Like we constantly learn new things about Andy. Well, we had multiple people right in with this fan catch, which is that during the Goodbye Toby episode, before he proposes to Angela, he actually calls his father Andrew Bernard.
对。然后他们把他重新命名为安德鲁。这太疯狂了。而且他弟弟现在叫小沃尔特。他们在评论音轨里确实分享过，他们乐于给安迪这么多背景故事。就像我们不断了解关于安迪的新事情。好吧，有多位观众写信提到了这个粉丝彩蛋，那就是在告别托比那一集里，在向安吉拉求婚之前，他实际上叫他的父亲安德鲁·伯纳德。
So he'd be Andrew Jr. Yeah. But here, his dad's name was Walter and his brother is Walter Jr. So their delight in creating backstory for Andy also included sort of ignoring the show Bible from time to time. Well, Andy's conversation about baby names, Pam says, was actually a nice distraction. She welcomes it. Yeah.
所以他应该是小安德鲁。对。但在这里，他爸爸的名字叫沃尔特，他弟弟叫小沃尔特。所以他们为安迪创造背景故事的乐趣也包括偶尔忽略剧集设定圣经。好吧，关于婴儿名字的对话，帕姆说，其实是一个很好的分心方式。她很欢迎。对。
Yeah. It's helping her not think about her labor. Well, that's all Michael needs to hear. Oh, yeah. He's like, conference room. And Jenna, this is an act break. Yeah. Once again, a call to the conference room like what Mindy talked about.
对。这帮她不去想分娩的事。好吧，这就是迈克尔需要听到的全部。哦，是的。他就像是，会议室。珍娜，这是一个幕间休息。对。又一次，像明迪讨论过的那样，把大家叫进会议室。
I think we should take an act break and we will be back to discuss what happens in that conference room. So much happens. We're back. Everyone's in the conference room and I'm going to kick this off with a fan question from Kelsey C. and Panama City Beach, Florida and Julie A. from Hudson, Wisconsin. They would like to know, is there a reason that almost everyone is wearing blue in this episode?
我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来讨论会议室里发生了什么。发生了太多事了。我们回来了。大家都进了会议室，我要以来自佛罗里达州巴拿马城海滩的凯尔西·C和来自威斯康星州哈德逊的朱莉·A的粉丝提问来开启这个话题。他们想知道，这一集里几乎每个人都穿蓝色衣服是有什么原因吗？
Huh. No. But Kelsey and Julie, I want you to know that this is something that was noticed by fans even when this episode aired. There was a whole forum on officetally.com all about it. Writer Danny Chun said he has no idea why this happened. But when I saw us all gathered in the conference room, I noticed the same thing. It's the blue episode.
嗯。没有。但凯尔西和朱莉，我想让你们知道，即使在这集播出的时候，这也是粉丝们注意到的细节。officetally.com 上有一个专门讨论这个的完整论坛。编剧丹尼·陈（Danny Chun）说他不知道为什么会这样。但当我看到我们大家都聚集在会议室里时，我也注意到了同样的情况。这就是那一集“蓝色集”。
Sometimes that happens. We had the purple episode. Mm-hmm. Good catch. Michael is going to open up the floor to ideas on how to keep Pam distracted. Do you notice who leaves really quickly? Stanley. Then Oscar and Angela.
有时候会这样。我们有过“紫色集”。嗯哼。观察得很仔细。迈克尔要让大家集思广益，想想怎么转移帕姆的注意力。你们注意到谁离开得最快了吗？斯坦利。然后是奥斯卡和安吉拉。
Well Phyllis offers to apply lipstick a la Molly Ringwald and Breakfast Club. Like when you tuck it in your bra? Yeah. Do new viewers get that reference when they watch this? Oh man. What a classic. I would have loved to see Phyllis do that. But no one takes her up on it.
菲莉丝提议像莫ly·林沃德（Molly Ringwald）在《早餐俱乐部》（Breakfast Club）里那样涂口红。就像把口红塞进胸罩里那种？对。现在的观众看这个能懂这个梗吗？天哪。真是经典。我本来很想看菲莉丝那样做的。但没人搭理她。
No. So Andy volunteers to do the evolution of dance in complete silence. He has to have complete silence. Yeah. So the evolution of dance is a real thing. It was a YouTube video created by Judson Lipley. It is a six minute video. And in the video, Judson does a few seconds of dance moves from throughout the 20th century.
没有。所以安迪自告奋勇要在绝对安静的情况下表演舞蹈的演变。他必须要求绝对安静。是的。所以舞蹈的演变是真实存在的。那是贾森·利普利（Judson Laipply）创作的一个 YouTube 视频。这是一个六分钟的视频。在视频中，贾森表演了 20 世纪各个年代的几个舞蹈动作。
It starts with the twist. He gets the worm in there. He does the cabbage patch. It's like little dance crazes through the years. It's the evolution of dance. It is. So this video was a huge sensation. It was actually the first YouTube video to reach 100 million views.
它从扭扭舞开始。他在里面跳了蠕虫舞。他跳了卷心菜娃娃舞。就像历年来的那些小舞蹈狂潮一样。这就是舞蹈的演变。确实如此。所以这个视频引起了巨大的轰动。它实际上是第一个观看次数达到 1 亿次的 YouTube 视频。
Wow. It held the Guinness World Record for most liked video for three years. It currently has 310 million views. I watched it in preparation for this episode. I had a smile on my face the whole time. It's so freaking charming. I haven't seen it. Oh, you gotta watch it.
哇。它保持了三年获得最多点赞视频的吉尼斯世界纪录。它目前的观看次数是 3.10 亿次。为了准备这一集，我看过这个视频。我全程都面带微笑。真是迷人得要命。我没看过。哦，你一定要看。
I was so tickled. I get why it's so popular. Judson is a professional keynote speaker and he performs the evolution of dance at the end of every one of his speaking events still to this day. He's still doing it. Still. So in the video, it's obviously all set to music and the music changes for each dance move.
我当时觉得太逗了。我明白为什么它这么受欢迎了。贾森是一名专业的发表主题演讲的演讲者，直到今天，他仍在每一次演讲活动结束时表演舞蹈的演变。他现在还在跳。还在跳。所以在视频中，显然全程都配了音乐，而且每个舞蹈动作音乐都会变。
It's this amazing medley of music. But Andy does it in silence. Randy Cordray said he was glad that Andy did it in silence because we would have had to license all those song clips and it would have cost a fortune. And Danny Chun said that Ed watched the evolution of dance YouTube video a bunch of times before we shot the scene and he's really doing the moves from this video. When he goes through the 80s, I was like laughing so hard. Our dances were ridiculous.
这是一首非常棒的串烧音乐。但安迪是在安静中表演的。兰迪·科德瑞（Randy Cordray）说他很高兴安迪是在安静中表演的，因为那样我们就必须购买所有这些歌曲片段的版权，那会花一大笔钱。丹尼·陈说，埃德在拍摄这个场景之前看了很多遍舞蹈演变的 YouTube 视频，他确实在模仿这个视频里的动作。当他跳到 80 年代的舞蹈时，我笑得前仰后合。我们的舞姿太荒谬了。
They made no sense. They were so weird. That would be such a fun workout. If he broke that down and taught it, I would want to learn it. Oh, my gosh. Should we try to learn it? Oh, no. There's some moves we can't do.
它们毫无逻辑。太诡异了。那会是一种非常有趣的锻炼方式。如果他把这个拆解并教给别人，我会想学。哦，天哪。我们应该试着学一下吗？哦，不。有些动作我们做不来。
I mean, I can't do the worm on the floor. It's not happening. No, no. My body didn't bend in a few different directions. Jenna, do you remember how much we laughed during that, how we could not get through it? Yes. And it was for a very specific reason. So specific.
我是说，我做不了地上的蠕虫舞。这不可能。不，不。我的身体没法朝好几个不同的方向弯曲。珍娜，你还记得我们在那期间笑得有多厉害吗，我们根本无法顺利拍完？是的。而且是有非常具体的原因。非常具体。
The sound of the pants. Ed's pants, these khaki pants he had on when he started moving. And also we were completely silent. Yes. And here's the thing. We did not know that the pants were going to do that. That was not planned. In fact, we got a fan question from Jaden in Bellingham, Washington, who said, the rustling
裤子的声音。埃德的裤子，他开始移动时穿的这种卡其裤。而且当时我们完全是安静的。是的。事情是这样的。我们不知道裤子会发出这种声音。那不是计划好的。事实上，我们收到了来自华盛顿州贝灵汉的杰登（Jaden）的一个粉丝提问，他说，安迪裤子的沙沙声
of Andy's pants makes this scene 10 times funnier. It really adds to the awkwardness. Did you add these as a sound effect? No. No. The sound his pants were making, I actually have it as an audio clip because I thought it was so funny. Oh my gosh.
让这个场景好笑了十倍。这真的增加了尴尬感。这是你们添加的音效吗？没有。没有。他裤子发出的声音，我其实把它当成了音频片段，因为我觉得太搞笑了。哦，天哪。
Can you play that? But imagine being only two feet away from that as it's happening. I remember us all laughing and being like, this is so absurd. And he's being so serious about it. He has to start over. Because Pam starts like clapping along and making some music. That throws him off. A few other people offer their distractions for Pam.
你能放一下吗？但想象一下，当它发生时，你离它只有两英尺远。我记得我们都在笑，觉得这太荒谬了。而且他表现得那么一本正经。他不得不重新开始。因为帕姆开始跟着拍手并发出一些音乐声。这让他分心了。其他几个人也为帕姆提供了分散注意力的点子。
Scarfy Ryan is back. Oh yeah. With his glasses and his orange swatch watch. He's going to read her a poem. He is. But Jenna, the scene was much longer. It's in deleted scenes. Oh, I remember.
戴围巾的瑞恩回来了。哦，是的。戴着眼镜，戴着他的橙色斯沃琪（Swatch）手表。他要给她读一首诗。是的。但是珍娜，这个场景要长得多。它在删减片段里。哦，我想起来了。
Oh my gosh. It's so funny. And the character Ryan calls out the documentary crew in a way I don't think we've heard. You have to hear it. I could read a poem I wrote. Hell yeah. Everybody shut up. Any similarities to real persons or events are very intentional.
哦，天哪。太搞笑了。而且瑞恩这个角色以一种我们前所未闻的方式公开叫板了纪录片摄制组。你必须听听看。我可以读一首我写的诗。太棒了。大家都闭嘴。如有雷同，纯属巧合。
Plastic love. You let me in your bed. But now, I sleep alone, trapped with the forgotten in my detritus home. I hope you're happy now. I hope it every day. In case you didn't figure it out yet. I'm the doll you threw away. Oh my gosh.
塑料之爱。你让我进了你的床。但现在，我独自入睡，被困在我破败之家的废墟与遗忘之中。我希望你现在快乐。我每天都这么希望。如果你还没发现的话。我就是你扔掉的那个玩偶。哦，天哪。
I'm sorry, that is so awful. It's awesome. I know, right? So bad. I just found it. I thought it was so funny. It's so awesome. Well, you just said you wrote it.
对不起，这太糟糕了。太棒了。我知道，对吧？太糟糕了。我刚找到的。我觉得太搞笑了。太棒了。好吧，你刚才说这是你写的。
I never said I wrote it. You did say that. I never said. Why would I have said I wrote it? I checked the tape. I never said I wrote it. I never said that. Check the tape.
我从来没说是我写的。你确实说过。我从来没说过。我为什么要说是我写的？我查了录像带。我从来没说是我写的。我从来没说。查录像带。
That's the first time any employee at Dunder Mifflin has asked them to playback footage. I wish they would have. Check the tape. After this scene, Jenna, the Creed runner would have come back. This is what happens. Angela is applying a little bit of chapstick. She's spraying herself with perfume. Creed interrupts her and hands her a necklace that says Angela in block letters.
这是邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的任何员工第一次要求回放录像。我希望他们当时回放了。查录像带。在这场戏之后，珍娜，克里德的支线剧情本来会回归。事情是这样的。安吉拉正在涂一点润唇膏。她给自己喷了点香水。克里德打断了她，递给她一条印有 block 字母“Angela”的项链。
Creed says to her, I want you to have this. And Angela goes, this is mine. And she said, I'll have you arrested. And Creed says, you can't arrest a ghost. I am so glad that you told me about this because in the next scene, when Angela meets Dwight in the warehouse and they start banging out their contract, I put down at eight minutes 43 seconds, is Angela's eye shadow bumped up? Yes.
克里德对她说，我想把这个送给你。安吉拉说，这是我的。她说，我要让人把你抓起来。克里德说，你抓不到一个鬼魂。我很高兴你跟我说了这个，因为在下一场戏中，当安吉拉在仓库里遇到德怀特，他们开始敲定合同时，我在 8 分 43 秒处记下了：安吉拉的眼影是不是加重了？是的。
She was judging herself. Yes. And I even went back to the scene in the break room and compared your makeup and yes. You have applied a little lip, a little extra bump on your eye. Uh-huh. Oh, I'm so proud of myself. Nice catch. Well, the note they gave to me was like over in the accounting nook, I'm making myself
她当时在自我审视。是的。我甚至回看了一下休息室的那个场景，对比了你的妆容，是的。你涂了一点唇彩，眼妆也稍微加重了一点。嗯哼。哦，我为自己感到骄傲。抓得好。好吧，他们给我的提示是，在会计角落那边，我正在让自己
ready to go meet Dwight. And they said spray perfume. And I remember doing this thing. And when I watched deleted scenes, it made me chuckle because I sprayed the perfume and the air around me and then walked under it. That was a thing they taught us to do in the 80s. I know. When the Bath and Body Works store, when the Bath and Body Works came out, they had this
准备好去见德怀特。他们说喷香水。我记得我做了这个动作。当我观看删减片段时，我忍不住笑了，因为我对着我周围的空气喷了香水，然后从下面走了过去。那是他们在 80 年代教我们做的一个动作。我知道。当那个身体和之美（Bath and Body Works）商店，当身体和之美开业时，他们有这种
like, do you remember that scent? It was called like vanilla? No, it was like white something and it supposedly had pheromones in it that would make you more attractive. In the store, they taught you how to put it on was to spray it and walk through it. I so remember doing that. I feel like I'm having all these memories flooding back to me about perfumes and scents. Are they still a thing today, we're just not connected to it because remember at the store,
就像，你还记得那个香味吗？好像叫香草味？不，那是一种类似白色的什么东西，据说里面有信息素，能让你更有吸引力。在店里，他们教你喷香水的方法是喷在空中然后走过去。我太记得我那样做了。我觉得我所有的记忆都涌上心头，关于香水和气味的记忆。现在它们还在吗，我们只是跟它脱节了，因为还记得在店里，
it was a whole thing, they had people who just like sprayed you with perfume as you walked by. Oh no, it's still happening. It does? It's still happening. Yeah. I went to Macy's and as I walked through like three different people wanted to spray me with perfume.
那可是个大阵仗，他们有人专门在你走过去的时候给你喷香水。哦不，现在还在发生。真的吗？现在还在发生。是的。我去梅西百货（Macy's）时，当我走过时，大约有三不同的人想给我喷香水。
But now they like spray a card and hand it to you. Yeah. But back then they just sprayed right into your face. They did. They really, really did. Wow. Yeah. Well, perfume was a thing.
但现在他们是把香水喷在卡片上递给你。是的。但当年他们是直接喷在你脸上。他们真的这么干。他们真的是、真的是这么干的。哇。是的。好吧，香水曾经很风靡。
It was a whole thing. We're going to learn a few things about this Dwight Angela warehouse rendezvous. First of all, they have a parenting contract to agree on, a pre-nate if you will. Here are some of the terms that Angela agrees to right away. Dwight wants the child breastfed by the mother for exactly six months and then weaned onto a nutrient-rich winter vegetable mush provided by the father Dwight Schrute, preferred to from here on out as Morpheus. Angela says agreed.
那可真是一件大事。我们要了解一些关于德怀特和安吉拉这次仓库幽会的事情。首先，他们要达成一份育儿合同，如果你愿意的话，可以叫婚前协议。以下是安吉拉立即同意的一些条款。德怀特要求孩子由母亲母乳喂养整整六个月，然后断奶，改吃由父亲德怀特·舒鲁特提供的营养丰富的冬季蔬菜泥，从今以后德怀特·舒鲁特首选被称为墨菲斯（Morpheus）。安吉拉说同意。
Agreed. Are you going to call him Morpheus? But there's one thing they don't agree on, baby names. Dwight says Ebenezer, Angela says Jedidiah, Dwight says Jonas, Angela says Jebediah, Dwight says Worf and that's it for Angela. No Star Trek names. Yeah. Dwight also wants her to agree that the baby will be a boy.
同意。你打算叫他墨菲斯吗？但有一件事他们无法达成一致，那就是孩子的名字。德怀特说埃比尼泽（Ebenezer），安吉拉说杰迪代亚（Jedidiah），德怀特说约拿（Jonas），安吉拉说杰贝迪亚（Jebediah），德怀特说沃尔夫（Worf），安吉拉受够了。没有《星际迷航》的名字。是的。德怀特还希望她同意这个孩子必须是个男孩。
Angela's like, I can't control that. He says you can. In fact, he says, quote, it's a simple matter of keeping the womb warm for two days after sex and then extremely cold for five months. And there was some additional dialogue in the script about this gender issue. Dwight said, I cannot leave Schrute Farms to a girl. I'll never be able to look another chicken in the eye. And Angela says, and I cannot teach a boy how to French braid, not again, not after
安吉拉觉得，我无法控制这个。他说你可以。事实上，他说，引述：“这很简单，只要在做爱后让子宫保持温暖两天，然后极度寒冷五个月。”剧本中关于这个性别问题还有一些额外的对话。德怀特说：“我不能把舒鲁特农场留给一个女孩。我再也没法正眼看别的鸡了。”安吉拉说：“而且我不能教一个男孩怎么法式编发，不能再来一次了，经历了我弟弟的事之后再也不能了。”我不知道这到底是怎么回事。鸡，法式编发，而且，这是我第一次听说安吉拉有个弟弟。她说过她有姐姐。是的。好吧，丹尼·陈说，德怀特想要一份婴儿合同的想法是查理·格兰迪（Charlie Grandi）提出的，大家都非常喜欢。
what happened to my brother. I don't know what is going on. The chickens, the French braiding, also, this is the first I've ever heard of Angela having a brother. She's talked about her sister. Yeah. Well, Danny Chun said that the idea of Dwight wanting a baby contract was Charlie Grandi's idea and everybody loved it.
他们觉得把生孩子当成一份正式协议完全符合德怀特的性格。丹尼说，生男孩的规则完全是他胡编乱造的。但我还是要说，从科学的角度来说，你查过这个吗？我本来就知道一点，但我确实查过以确认一下。德怀特的理论有一点道理吗？没有。哦，谢天谢地。
They felt like it totally fit in Dwight's character to approach baby making as a formal agreement. Danny said he completely made up the rules for making a boy. But I do want to say, scientifically speaking, did you look this up? I kind of knew it, but I did look it up to confirm it. Is there any truth to Dwight's theory? No. Oh, thank God.
德怀特的理论完全没道理。什么？那是完全胡编乱造的。好吧。但据说男孩的精子游动速度要快得多，但也比女孩的精子死得更快。所以如果有卵子在等待、准备好了，男孩的精子很可能会最先到达。但如果卵子还没到，女孩的精子可以到处闲逛。它们寿命长一点。
Not to Dwight's theory. What? That's completely made up. Okay. But boy sperm supposedly moves much faster, but also dies faster than girl sperm. So if there is an egg waiting, ready to go, boy sperm will most likely get to it first. But if the egg isn't there yet, the girl sperm can hang out. They live a little longer.
它们会等待卵子。我读的那篇文章还说，女孩的精子非常健康。生命力顽强。它们得闲逛一会儿。没错。所以这就是为什么你经常生男孩或女孩的原因。你知道的，是卵子已经准备好在等待了？还是花了一点时间？
They'll wait for it. The article that I read also said that girl sperm is very fit. It's hearty. It's got to hang out for a bit. That's right. So this is often why you get a boy or a girl. It's, you know, was the egg sort of ready and waiting? Or did it take a minute?
然后女孩的精子的寿命就比男孩的精子长。真希望有人能向亨利八世解释这一点。是的，一点也没错。回到会议室，帕姆的宫缩越来越频繁，迈克尔有了一个主意。他说，我们列一份能让你进入产程的事情的清单，然后我们反其道而行之来减缓它。所以，举个例子，能帮助推动产程进展的事情之一就是刺激乳头。所以迈克尔说，谁也不准碰帕姆的乳头。
And so then the girl sperm outlasted the boy sperm. Wish someone could have explained that to Henry VIII. Yeah, no kidding. So back in the conference room, Pam's contractions are more frequent and Michael has an idea. He says, let's get a list of things that make you go into labor and will do the opposite to slow it down. So for example, something that can help move your labor along is to stimulate the nipples. So Michael says, nobody touch Pam's nipples.
是的。他说，把帕姆的乳头想象成托比的会阴（grundle）。我不知道那是什么。所以我谷歌了一下会阴。那是什么？会阴，伙计们，你们知道会阴是什么吗？我很高兴地向大家汇报，我这辈子头一次，我对这个一无所知。根据互联网的说法，它是你的蛋蛋和菊花之间的区域。
Yes. He says, think of Pam's nipples as Toby's grundle. I didn't know what that was. So I Googled grundle. What is it? A grundle, guys, do you guys know what a grundle is? I'm so happy to report for once in my life now, I've got nothing for you. According to the internet, it's the area between your balls and your butthole.
你描述的是会阴（taint），我的朋友。那是会阴。好吧，会阴（grundle）也是这个意思。听着，我要读给你听。会阴（Grundle），美国俚语，会阴部（perineum），肛门和生殖器之间的区域。好吧。会阴。就是这样。
You're describing the taint, my friend. That's a taint. Well, that's what the grundle is as well. Listen, I'm going to read it to you. Grundle, U.S. slang, the perinium, the area between the anus and the genitals. Okay. Grundle. There you go.
你能快点查一下 taint 吗？我的意思是，我会查 taint 的。我爱我的搜索引擎。会阴（Taint）。哦，当我谷歌 taint 时，弹出的第一个词就是 taint 对比 grundle。哦，然后呢？
Will you look up taint real quick? I mean, I will look up taint. I love my search engine. Taint. Oh, when I Googled taint, it's the first thing that came up, said taint versus grundle. Oh, and? I'm going to, I'm clicking on it. Oh, my goodness.
我要，我正在点击它。哦，天哪。这是维基百科俚语部分的内容。Taint、grundle、gooch 和 durf 都是同一个东西，根据你来自哪里，描述的是你身体的同一部位。哦，我猜山姆，中西部人喜欢用 taint。是的，那就是 taint。那 grundle 是东海岸的词吗？我只知道 taint，而且我绝对没听过 durf。我相信那是一个高尔夫视频。
This is in Wikipedia slang section. The taint, grundle, gooch, and durf are all the same thing, describing the same part of your body depending on where you are from. Oh, I guess Sam, the Midwesterners are going with taint. Yeah, that's the taint. Is grundle a east coast thing, then? I only know taint, and I certainly have never heard of durf. I believe that's a golf video.
我还以为那是高尔夫里的一个角色。好吧，这段对话还在继续，梅雷迪思说，你知道吗，我有一件衬衫她应该穿，因为它的胸部区域是镂空的。迈克尔说，那就去拿来呀。是的。然后凯文提出了辛辣食物。是的，因为能诱发产程的事情之一就是吃辛辣食物。所以凯文说，把辛辣食物塞进她的屁股里。
I thought that was a golf character. Well, this conversation continues where Meredith says, you know what, I have a shirt she should wear because it's got like the boob area cut out. Michael's like, well, then go get it. Yeah. And then Kevin throws out spicy foods. Yeah, because one of the things that can induce labor is eating spicy foods. So Kevin says, shove spicy food up her butt.
哦，天哪。我们收到了印第安纳州印第安纳波利斯的斯蒂芬妮·E（Stephanie E.）的粉丝提问，她想知道，那句台词是即兴发挥吗？因为这一集的笑场花絮中，凯文说，让辛辣食物从她体内出来，我们所有人都笑得停不下来。她说，第一次看到这句话时，我和我弟弟笑得前仰后合。这完全出乎我们的意料。这是斯蒂芬妮有史以来最喜欢的凯文台词。
Oh, my gosh. We got a fan question from Stephanie E. in Indianapolis, Indiana, who wanted to know, was that line an improvisation? Because in the bloopers for this episode, Kevin says, make spicy food come out of her, and we all can't stop laughing. She said, this line made my brother and I laugh so hard the first time we saw it. It took us by complete surprise. It is Stephanie's favorite Kevin line of all time.
所以，斯蒂芬妮，“把辛辣食物塞进她屁股里”是剧本里的台词。但在拍摄当天，有人提议让凯文说“让辛辣食物从她体内出来”。这把我们逗得笑得拍不拢腿，根本没办法顺利演下去。这是一个片段。吃辛辣食物。那相反的是什么？让辛辣食物从她体内出来。好吧，不，不。
So Stephanie, the line shove spicy food up her butt was the scripted line. But on the day, there was a pitch that Kevin say, make spicy food come out of her. And that so tickled us that we couldn't get through it. Here is a clip. Eat spicy foods. What is the opposite of that? Make spicy foods come out of her. Okay, no, no.
吃辛辣食物。好吧。好吧。那相反的是什么？让辛辣食物从她体内出来。哦，好吧，不，不，我们不这么做，帕姆。好吧，那是什么？吃辛辣食物。
Eat spicy foods. Okay. Okay. What is the opposite of that? Take spicy foods come out of her. Oh, okay, nope, nope, we're not doing that, Pam. Okay, so what is it? Eat spicy foods.
那相反的呢？制作辛辣食物。到那个时候，我们其实都在预料它了。但关于那个片段我最喜欢的另一件事，安吉（Ange），它向你展示了我们是如何迅速让自己重新调整状态的。就像如果我们笑了，我们会说，好吧，好吧，好吧，再来一次。就像每个人都以多快的速度迅速回到角色中，并再次给出相同的cue一样。
And the opposite of that? Make spicy food. By that point, we were just all anticipating it. But the other thing I love about that clip, Ange, is it shows you we just quickly would reset ourselves. Like if we were laughing, we'd be like, okay, okay, okay, go again. And just like how quickly everybody snaps right back into character and gives the same cue again.
就像我们尝试过的一样。我们每天都这样做。每天我们都会说，好了，伙计们，拜托，我们走吧。我们能行的。我们能行的。是的。吉姆受够了。他快崩溃了。
Like we tried. We did that daily. Daily we would just be like, okay, guys, come on, let's go. We got it. We got it. Yeah. Jim has had enough. He is losing it.
他有一段非常棒的独白，他说，我比办公室里的任何人都要了解帕姆。很明显她疯了，但每个人都想说我疯了，但我没疯。她疯了。我没疯。她疯了。我只是在翻阅所有的怀孕书籍，五到七分钟，五到七分钟，差六分钟，但其实不是五到七分钟。这段独白真的让我感到非常开心。
He has this great talking head where he says, I know Pam better than anyone in this office. And obviously she's gone crazy, but everybody wants to say that I'm crazy, but I'm not crazy. She's crazy. I'm not crazy. She's crazy. I'm just flipping through all the pregnancy books, five to seven minutes, five to seven minutes, six minutes different, but not really five to seven minutes. This talking head really delighted me.
他们在 DVD 里谈过这个。丹尼和格雷格说这是一场重拍。它不在拍摄剧本里。他们这样做是因为他们想展现吉姆这个角色的视角，并且表明他其实也不是完全理智的。所以，安吉，我记得第一次看这一集首播的时候，因为这段独白是一场重拍，我对此一无所知。就像我不记得在剧本里读过它一样。
They talked about it on the DVD. Danny and Greg said it was a reshoot. It wasn't in the shooting draft. And they did it because they wanted to show Jim's character's perspective and that he wasn't being completely rational either. So Ange, I remember watching this episode the first time it aired originally and because this talking head had been a reshoot, I had no knowledge of it. Like I didn't remember reading it in the script.
我不记得拍过它。这让我大吃一惊，我觉得约翰的表演太精彩了，以至于我给他打电话说：“约翰，那段独白太棒了。”就像我记得给他打电话，实时称赞他一样。我喜欢这段独白，当它再次出现时，我想：太好了，就是这样。是的。太棒了。好吧，正如你所看到的，吉姆的情绪开始逐渐失控，你也能看到帕姆的情绪
I didn't remember shooting it. It took me by surprise and I found John's performance so delightful that I called him on the phone and I was like, John, that talking head was amazing. Like I remember calling him and complimenting him in real time. I love this talking head and when it came up again, I was like, yes, there it is. Yeah. It's so good. Well, as you see Jim starting to build in his spiral, you're starting to see Pam's spiral
也在失控。这将把我们带到停车场。吉姆在车里。他准备好走了。帕姆敲了敲车窗，非常平静地说：“你知道的，我不会上车的，因为那样你只会把我送到医院里去。”然后你猜怎么着？是的。
too. And it's going to take us to the parking lot. Jim is in the car. He's ready to go. Pam knocks on the window and very calmly says, you know, I'm not going to get in because then you're just going to drive me to the hospital. And then guess what happens? Yeah.
她说漏嘴了，说他们怀的是个女宝宝。吉姆说，什么？哦，天哪。而约翰演得简直绝了。这个时刻让我感动得热泪盈眶。当吉姆意识到自己将要成为一个小女孩的父亲时，这是最甜蜜的事情。我太喜欢了。顺便说一句，你注意到光线有多美了吗？
She slips up and says that they're having a baby girl. And Jim's like, what? Oh man. And John just crushed it. This moment made me tear up. When Jim realizes he's going to be a father to a little girl, it is the sweetest thing. I loved it. Side note, did you notice how beautiful the lighting was?
非常漂亮。又一次，吉姆和帕姆在黄金时刻的室外，他们在评论音轨里甚至还谈到了这一点。这个场景看起来有多棒。塞思（Seth）说，是的，我们只是运气好。那是那种神奇的黄金时刻。嗯哼。好吧，编剧丹尼·陈说，他们在编剧室里反复讨论过吉姆和帕姆究竟应该生个男孩还是女孩。
Very pretty. Once again, Jim and Pam outside at Golden Hour, they even talked about that on the commentary. How great this scene looks. Seth was like, yeah, we just lucked out. It was that sort of magical Golden Hour. Mm-hmm. Well, writer Danny Chun said that they went back and forth in the writer's room over whether Jim and Pam should have a boy or a girl.
他说在写剧本快结束时，他们想出了这个让帕姆说漏嘴的主意。不管出于什么原因，他们只是觉得这个时刻作为一个女宝宝会效果更好。他还补充说，有一个女儿的布伦特·福斯特（Brent Forrester）一直在坚定地争取生个女孩。所以他可以说是支持生女孩呼声最高的人。好吧，我觉得效果很好。我只是觉得看到吉姆作为那种女儿奴爸爸，你知道的，那种顿悟涌上心头的感觉太甜蜜了。嗯哼。
He said toward the end of writing the script, they came up with this idea of Pam kind of spilling the beans. And for whatever reason, they just felt like this moment would work better as a baby girl. He also added that Brent Forrester, who has a daughter, was like relentlessly pushing for it to be a girl. So he was kind of the loudest in favor of girl. Well, I thought it worked. I thought just seeing Jim as that girl dad, you know, and having that realization come
好吧，吉姆也注意到了一件事。帕姆，你换衣服了吗？嗯哼。她换了。因为她羊水破了。然后她走开了。
across him was so sweet. Mm-hmm. Well, Jim's also going to notice something. Pam, did you change clothes? Mm-hmm. She did. Because her water broke. And then she walks away.
就在他刚有点像，好吧，我们没事。我们没事。的时候。是的。好吧，我怀我女儿的时候也破水了。那是星期六。嗯哼。我们那天原本打算请人在家里吃烧烤。所以我上楼了。
Just when he was sort of being like, OK, we're OK. We're OK. Yeah. Well, my water broke with my daughter. It was a Saturday. Mm-hmm. And we were going to have people over for a barbecue that day. So I went upstairs.
我正准备走进淋浴间。然后就感觉好像有很多水流出来，但我当时还没进淋浴间呢。我真的很困惑，然后它就一直流。我就想，我觉得我现在不是在尿尿，但我当时没有任何宫缩，就像没有任何产兆一样。所以我的羊水先破了，这让人很困惑。是的。因为我不知道会发生这种事。
I was about to step into the shower. And it was kind of like a lot of water was there, but I wasn't in the shower yet. I was real confused, and then it just like kept happening. And I was like, I don't think I'm peeing right now, but I wasn't having any contractions, like no signs of labor. So my water broke first, which was confusing. Yeah. Because I didn't know that could happen.
我不知道这可以作为第一个征兆。所以你猜怎么着？我们那天没有办烧烤派对。我本想说，我打赌你们的计划变了。变得那叫一个快。好吧，你可能会认为帕姆羊水破了之后会有点动力，但她并没有。不。
I didn't know that that can be the first thing. So guess what? We did not have a barbecue that day. I was going to say, I bet your plans changed. They changed real fast. Well, you would think Pam would sort of get motivated when her water broke, but she does not. No.
她还是留在公司。她哪儿也不去。她有一段独白，在里面她说，她很好。不用急。她会去医院的，或者也许她不会。好吧，来自伦敦的凯蒂·P（Katie P.）发现了粉丝们的穿帮。帕姆在 13 分 21 秒的独白中，衣服穿错了。她的羊水破了。
She's still staying at work. She's not going anywhere. She has a talking head where she says, she's fine. There's no rush. She'll get to the hospital, or maybe she won't. Well, big fan catch from Katie P. in London. Pam's talking head at 13 minutes, 21 seconds, is in the wrong clothes. Her water broke.
她换了衣服，但现在她又穿回了以前的衣服。是的。我们把它剪辑调换了。那是剧本里安排在较早时候的一段独白，但他们把它放到了这里。好吧，我们希望你不会注意到，但你还是注意到了。他们在评论音轨里说，他们太喜欢你在那段独白中的表现了，所以他们根本不在乎。你穿错了戏服。
She changed clothes, but now she's back in her old clothes. Yeah. We moved it around. That was a talking head that we had in the script for earlier, but they put it here. And well, we were hoping you wouldn't notice, but you noticed. They said on the commentary that they loved your take so much in that talking head, they didn't care. You were in the wrong wardrobe.
他们当时就觉得，哦，好吧，是的。我非常喜欢休息室里的下一场戏。帕姆决心和凯文一起享受她的终极饕餮大餐，而吉姆却说，不，是时候去医院了。迈克尔也说，是时候去医院了。然后帕姆彻底崩溃了，说，我不去。我不去。最后她终于承认她害怕去。
They were like, oh, well, yeah. I absolutely love this next scene in the break room. Pam is determined to have her ultra-feast with Kevin, and Jim is like, no, it's time to go to the hospital. Michael's like, it's time to go to the hospital. And Pam just loses it and is like, I'm not going. I'm not going. And then she finally admits she's scared to go.
然后房间里的所有男人都把手放在她的肚子上，给她加油打气。这是我在《办公室》里有史以来最喜欢拍摄的场景之一。我想我最喜欢的事情是凯文也在那里。是的。这让它变得更加好笑了。她在这个场景里是个不苟言笑的正经人。我知道这有多疯狂。珍娜，当我看到它时，我太喜欢你的表演了。
And then all the men in the room put their hands on her belly and give her a pep talk. This was one of my favorite scenes to shoot of all time on the office. I think my favorite thing is that Kevin is there. Yes. It made it even funnier. She is the straight man in this scene. I know how crazy is that. Gemma, as I watched it, I loved your performance so much.
我也纳闷你是怎么忍住不笑场的。因为当他们把手都放在帕姆大肚便便的肚子上，说“你能行的”时候。他们表现得那么真诚，但他们都在摸她的肚子。信不信由你，那并不是让我们笑场的原因。我们挺过了那一关。尽管我很想读一下那个时刻的剧本提示。哦，拜访。
I also don't know how you kept a straight face. Because when they all put their hands on Pam's pregger belly, and they were like, you got this. They were being so sincere, but they were all touching her belly. Believe it or not, that is not the moment that made us break. We were able to get through that. Even though I do want to read the script note for that moment. Oh, please.
这个场景的剧本提示是：迈克尔单膝跪地。他说话声音非常小，而且有一种诡异的气息。所以他们所有人摸我肚子的那个举动，是我们当场想出来的主意。原本只打算拍成那种帕姆对迈克尔的经典时刻。但我们实在没法拍下去的时刻是，当珍娜（注：应为帕姆）在抓狂时，迈克尔把吉姆（注：原文误写为Gemma，指Jim）推到门板上，说：“稳住情绪”。每次史蒂夫演那句台词时，语气都会稍微加强一点，比如“稳住情绪，稳住情绪”。就像他用了一种很奇怪的语气演那句台词。
The script note for this scene is, Michael gets down on one knee. He speaks very quietly and weirdly breathy. So that bit of them all touching my belly, that was an idea we came up with in the moment. It was originally going to be just one of those Pam to Michael moments. But the moment we couldn't get through is when Gemma is freaking out and Michael kind of pins him up against the door and says, hold it together. Every time Steve did that line, a little bit more like, hold it together, hold it together. Like he did like a weird take on it.
就像迈克尔在说要稳住情绪，但他自己明显快失控了。是的。我其实有一段音频片段。离四分钟和三分钟还有多久，迈克尔？没关系。两分钟太快了。我们没事。我们没事。
Like Michael's saying hold it together, but he's clearly losing it. Yes. I actually have an audio clip. What happened to 4 and 3, Michael? It's okay. Two minutes is too soon. We're fine. We're fine.
所以两分钟有很大的区别。你现在必须稳住情绪。我告诉过你要热敷。五分钟到两分钟。离四分钟和三分钟还有多久，因为两分钟对我们没用。过来，过来。不。什么？
So two minutes is a very big difference. You gotta hold it together right now. I told you to warm it. Five minutes to two. What happened to 4 and 3 because two minutes doesn't do us any good. Come here, come here. No. What?
你现在必须稳住情绪，好吗。你听到了吗？太搞笑了。你必须稳住情绪。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。那种时刻的混乱感也是，哦，天哪。哦，我们拍那场戏时玩得太开心了。
You gotta hold it together okay now. Do you hear that? It's so funny. You gotta hold it together. It's so funny. It was so funny. of the chaos in the moment too, oh man. Oh, that we had so much fun doing that scene.
我甚至不希望它结束。他们可能拍了大量的素材，因为我们太喜欢发挥了。好吧，他们决定的一件事是，帕姆要生了。我是说，宫缩间隔两分钟，他们等太久了，是时候出发了。然后休息室里这种混乱的能量
I don't even think we wanted it to end. They probably have so much footage from it because we were so milking it. Well, one thing they decide is that Pam is having the baby. I mean, contractions are two minutes apart, they've waited too long, it's time to go. Then this chaotic energy from the break room
现在蔓延到了办公大厅。迈克尔问，我的待产包准备好了吗？还没准备好。他在征求每个人的意见。德怀特要给帕姆测量宫颈，这到底是怎么回事？在这片混乱中，我最喜欢的一句台词是迈克尔问，我应该带一本字典吗？奥斯卡看着镜头。
now spills into the bullpen. Michael's like, is my go bag ready? It's not ready. He's getting advice from everyone. Dwight's gonna measure Pam's cervix, like what is happening? My favorite line in this chaos is when Michael says, should I take a dictionary and Oscar looks to camera?
奥斯卡看着镜头说的那种眼神，然后说，医院提供字典，带本同义词词典吧。是的，我也超喜欢那个。哦，天哪。我在这个场景里还发现了一个背景穿帮。是什么？当大家都在往外冲的时候，你注意到帕姆的大衣是一件很大很宽松的格子大衣吗？
And the way Oscar looked at camera and said, the hospital provides dictionaries, bring a thesaurus. Yes, I loved that too. Oh my gosh. I also have a background catch in this scene. What is it? As everyone's rushing out, did you notice Pam's coat is a big oversized plaid coat?
那不是帕姆平常穿的大衣。哦，是的。那是因为有一个删减场景，它是克里德支线剧情的一部分，克里德在他们离开时跑向帕姆，把他的大衣递给她，并说：“给你，让我来帮帮你。”而她说：“谢谢，等等，这是谁的大衣？”
It's not Pam's regular coat. Oh yeah. That is because there was a deleted scene that is part of this Creed runner where Creed runs up to Pam as they're leaving and he gives her his coat and he says, here, let me help you with this. And she says, thanks, wait, whose coat is this?
克里德轻声说：“帕姆，我求求你，别这样。”帕姆说：“什么？”然后吉姆说：“我们走吧，我们走吧”，催促大家赶紧出去。所以帕姆实际上是穿着克里德的大衣去医院的。啊。如果你去看看 16 分钟处的剧集，
And Creed says softly, Pam, I'm begging you, don't do this. And Pam goes, what? And the gem goes, let's go, let's go, and rushes everyone out. So Pam actually is wearing Creed's coat to the hospital. Aw. And if you go to the episode at 16 minutes,
如果你定格画面，你可以看到克里德拿着它跑进来。真的吗？就在那里，但非常短暂。然后那个场景被剪掉了，他们只是把你催着弄出去了。好吧，德怀特要带头为去医院的车队开路。但首先，哦，天哪，迈克尔，迈克尔，那就是我上周看到鹿的地方。大家都停下。
if you freeze it, you can see Creed running in with it. Really? Right there, but it's so brief. And then the scene was cut and they just usher you out. Well, Dwight is gonna lead this motorcade to the hospital. But first, oh my gosh, Michael, Michael, that's where I saw the deer last week. Everyone stop.
我太喜欢那个了。它就在那边。我太喜欢了。好吧，我们有迈克尔开着一辆车，帕姆和吉姆坐在后座，德怀特在护送他们。他可太喜欢护送别人了。他在车顶上放了一个警示灯。
I loved that so much. It was right over there. I loved it. Well, we've got Michael driving one car with Pam and Jim in the back seat and Dwight is escorting them. He loves to escort people. He put his light on top of the roof of the car.
是的，这可不太妙，因为警察要把德怀特拦下来了。剧本上说，德怀特减速并把车停在路边。就在他这样做的时候，他神不知鬼不觉地把双节棍、一把剑和一把战斧从副驾驶的车窗扔了出去。嗯哼。好吧，我要告诉你们的是，在这些场景中，史蒂夫实际上并没有开车。
Yeah, that's not gonna go so well because the police are gonna pull Dwight over. In the script, it said Dwight slows down and pulls over. As he does, he discreetly throws nunchucks, a sword, and a battle axe out the passenger window. Mm-hmm. Well, I'll have you know that Steve was not actually driving in these scenes.
车子挂在拖车架上。它是在被拉着走。我们用口红摄像头（lipstick cameras）拍摄了这些镜头，摄像头到拖车车辆有实况转播，导演就坐在拖车上，可以在小监视器上观看我们在做什么，并通过对讲机给我们提意见。
The car was hooked up to a tow rig. It was being pulled. We filmed these using lipstick cameras and there was a live feed from the cameras to the tow rig vehicle, which the director was riding in and could watch what we were doing on little monitors and give us notes on walkie-talkies.
只是对讲机。老派，老科技。至于德怀特车子的外观，是雷恩（Rainn）在开。他的镜头是车对车拍摄的，这意味着有一名摄像师在一辆车里拍摄他的车。但对于德怀特车子内部的镜头，我们再次使用了拖车架和口红摄像头。
Just walkie-talkies. Old school, old tech. For the exterior of Dwight's car, Rain was driving. His footage was done car to car, meaning that there was a camera operator in one car shooting his car. But for inside of Dwight's car, we used the tow rig and the lipstick camera again.
所以，比如当他把东西扔出窗外时，那是，你知道的，拖车架，但当他从停车场猛踩油门冲出去，你看到他整辆车的时候，那是雷恩。是的。我非常喜欢帕姆意识到她把 iPod 忘在家里的那个时刻。嗯哼。
So like when he's throwing the stuff out of the window, that was, you know, a tow rig, but when he's peeling out of the parking lot and you see his whole car, that's Rain. Yeah. I love the moment when Pam realizes that she left her iPod at home. Mm-hmm.
珍娜，我为医院做了一整张播放列表。我有我的音乐。我记得。是的。我去医院看望刚生完孩子的你时，即使在她出生后，你还想让我放那个音乐。是的。所以当我看到这个时，我觉得我会像，
Jenna, I made a whole playlist for the hospital. I had my music. I remember. Yeah. When I came to visit you after you gave birth, you wanted me to play it even after she was born. Yes. And so when I saw this, I felt like I would be like,
我的播放列表。嗯哼。我也会是一样的。好吧，丹尼分享了帕姆的产歌是什么。是什么？Cass McCombs 的《Dreams Come True Girl》。这里原本还有一整场戏，是帕姆在第二部分分娩时播放这首歌的，
my playlist. Mm-hmm. I would be the same way. Well, Danny shared what Pam's birth song was. What was it? Dreams Come True Girl by Cass McCombs. And there was a whole scene where Pam plays it in delivery part two,
但为了控制时长被剪掉了。啊。所以她确实有一首歌。迈克尔想到了一个让她能拿到歌的主意。他要给德怀特打电话，说，去帕姆和吉姆的家里，拿她的 iPod，把它带到医院。嗯哼。
but it was cut for time. Aw. So she really did have a song. And Michael has an idea for how she can get it. He's going to call Dwight on the phone, say, go to Pam and Jim's house, get her iPod, bring it to the hospital. Mm-hmm.
这将为第二部分铺垫一个很大的故事情节。帕姆正试图告诉德怀特钥匙在哪里，而他却说，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，别告诉我。那是什么？我不知道。哦。好吧，他们确实去到了医院。嗯哼。
This is going to set up a big old storyline for part two. Pam is trying to tell Dwight where the key is and he's like, la, la, la, la, la, don't tell me. What is that? I don't know. Oh. Well, they do make it to the hospital. Mm-hmm.
他们确实去了，吉姆带着帕姆进去，因为他是孩子父亲。迈克尔问，我能做什么？吉姆说，去停车。迈克尔随手把车停在路边。救护车的工作人员说，你不能把车停在这里。他把钥匙随手扔进草地里，说，我想我刚才已经停了。
They do, Jim is going to take Pam in because he is the father. And Michael's like, what can I do? Jim's like, go park the car. Michael just sort of pulls the car to the side. The ambulance guy goes, you can't park here. And he chunks the keys into the grass and goes, I think I just did.
是的。在 DVD 上，丹尼说史蒂夫其实把钥匙扔进了一种水沟排水槽似的东西里，他们后来不得不意外地把钥匙捞出来。哦，不。是的。不过，好吧，迈克尔就是把钥匙随手一扔。好吧，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州阿拉纳（Alana）的粉丝提问。
Yeah. On the DVD, Danny said that Steve actually threw them in what was kind of like a gutter trench thing they had to go fish them out of by accident. Oh, no. Yeah. But yeah, Michael just tosses the keys. Well, we got a fan question from Alana in Pennsylvania.
你们拍摄的医院是真的还是搭的景？这是真实医院的外景。我们在加利福尼亚州伯班克的圣约瑟夫医院（St. Joseph's）。我知道那在哪儿。是的。这就是这一集结束的方式，但这一集原本的结尾是帕姆和吉姆办理住院手续。
Was the hospital you filmed at real or a set? This was the exterior of a real hospital. We were at St. Joseph's in Burbank, California. I know right where that is. Yep. So that is how this episode ends, but this episode originally ended with Pam and Jim checking into the hospital.
事实上，这个删减片段中的一个镜头曾出现在这一集的宣传片中。然后它从未播出，粉丝们都疯了。它也没有在第二部分里出现。你看到的是吉姆用轮椅推着帕姆进医院。他亲吻她的额头说，我爱你。这出现在所有通往这一集的宣传片中。然后每个人都问，吉姆在医院说“我爱你”的那个镜头在哪里？
In fact, a moment from this deleted scene was in the promos for this episode. And then it never aired and fans went crazy. It didn't end up in part two either. What you see is Jim wheeling Pam into the hospital. He kisses her forehead and says, I love you. And that was in all the promos leading up to this episode. And then everyone was like, where's the moment
同样在这个删减片段中，迈克尔停好车走了进来。他坐在候诊室里。他拿出一件定制衬衫，上面写着：“Beasley 助手，出生于 09 到 010”。他做了 T 恤。他做了一件 T 恤。
where Jim says I love you in the hospital? Also in this deleted scene, Michael comes in from parking the car. He's sitting in the waiting room. He takes out a custom shirt that says, helper Beasley birth 09 to 010. He made shirts. He made a shirt.
但丹尼分享说，由于第二部分的开场是迈克尔带着气球进入医院，当这两集连播时，这看起来时间跳跃得太大了。所以这就是他们剪掉帕姆和吉姆办理住院手续这一场景的原因。好吧，下周，我们要谈论《分娩（第二部分）》。吉姆和帕姆之间有很多删减片段。
But Danny shared that since part two opens with Michael entering the hospital with balloons, it just seemed like too much of a time jump for when the episodes aired back to back. So that is why they cut the scene of Pam and Jim checking in. Well, next week, we're going to be talking about delivery part two. There are a lot of deleted scenes between Jim and Pam.
它们都在 DVD 上。现在我迫不及待地想与你们分享它们，因为我认为额头上的那个吻是他们几个小时内最后的几个温情时刻之一。同样在下周，我们有一位特邀嘉宾。我的丈夫李·柯克（Lee Kirk）将来到我们的工作室，和我们一起畅谈扮演哺乳顾问克拉克（Clark）的经历。我等不及了。
They're on the DVD. And now I can't wait to share them with you because I think that kiss on the forehead was like one of their last civil moments for a few hours. Also next week, we're going to have a special guest. My husband, Lee Kirk, is going to be in the studio with us talking all about playing Clark, the lactation consultant. I cannot wait.
一定会非常有趣。祝大家度过美好的一周。非常感谢你们收听我们的节目并和我们一起重温。我们爱你们。回头见。感谢收听“办公室辣妈”（Office Ladies）。“办公室辣妈”由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）联合制作。
It's going to be so fun. You guys have a great week. Thanks so much for listening to us and rewatching with us. We love you. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）担任执行制作人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kieffer）。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubaco）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室辣妈”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium,
请使用优惠码 OFFICE。保留所有权利。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
use code OFFICE. All rights reserved. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请使用代码OFFICE。保留所有权利。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。